Like a boss.
Oh,
by the way,
that I gotta tell you something that dopey a brand thing on fucking Instagram
and I'm like,
that can't get over that clip.
Now,
that little shit,
yellowed with dead bouncer,
the bounce it goes,
get out,
get out of my face,
you little shit or whatever.
And the kid is so beside himself.
He said,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
Do you have any idea what the fuck my dad does?
[inaudible]
I cannot believe that a man said that to another man.
Do you have any idea what the fuck my dad does?
It's like,
why is I'm gonna talk to your dad there,
son,
I'm talking to you.
What the fuck do you do?
Yeah,
other than by little sharks.
But what I love if you,
I've watched that video so many times after the,
he fucking throws that little shit,
which is so sad.
Satisfying to watching to watch when you listen to his friends,
Dave just like,
oh dude,
you are fucked.
You up.
You just fucked up dude.
And the kid gets up.
I'm like,
oh,
why does he know some taekwondo?
What's going down?
And he goes,
you just fucked up mad.
They all walked away,
right?
What they were so convinced at this bouncer was fucked into the point.
I was sitting there like,
I was feeling like I'm satisfied.
Like,
dude,
I want to know what the fuck you dad does.
Do you have any idea what the fuck my dad does?
I just loved the way she says,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
Like he can't.
He's like,
are you seriously challenging me right now?
Do you have any idea what the fuck my dad,
what does he do?
Does he torture people for the CIA?
What the fuck does he do?
Oh,
my dad does for a living and cleans toilets.
Come on.
Hey owns this major toilet cleaning company that's big.
It's huge actually.
And he is an incredible asshole.